let's jump to this story we got from
CNBC and it's you know both sad and
funny at the same time resumes including
they them pronouns are more likely to be
overlooked new report fines well gee I'm
not I'm I'm so shocked inclusivity
shouldn't just be present in the
workplace it should be practiced during
the hiring process but unfortunately
non-binary job Seekers are facing clear
biases biases during their job search
according to a new report from
business.com a business resource
platform over 80 percent of non-binary
people believe that identifying as
non-binary would hurt their job search
similarly 51 believe their gender
identity has affected their workplace
experience very or somewhat negatively
I gotta I gotta I gotta make a point if
you wrote down on your resume that you
were
that you identify as a globa dupe
right
they're not going to hire you they're
gonna I don't I don't I don't know what
this is weird and they're going to say
me Dwight they don't
hires here not not what my point is this
no we do we do actually but my point is
if an employer looks at a resume and
they're like what the does that mean
they're not they're not going to hire
you can be like I have no idea what this
is you have to put it to the back of the
pile immediately yeah they're gonna say
look man look I don't know what you're
talking about at first like is they them
like what is this non-binary is a
made-up thing in the past several years
no one even understands I know that
gender and sex are different and
sexuality is different than sex you
could be male you can have a sexuality
that's I like guys or girls but like
this the reason that jobs don't ask for
your your sexual preference when you're
signing up because you don't want to be
discriminated against why don't offer it
like literally if you hire that you are
hiring a lawsuit you are hiring an HR
problem if you hire someone no but do
these do these uh resumes go to a
separate pile that then get sent to HR
so when they're like I need a diversity
hire they got their stack right there uh
not if you're smart I'm not saying it's
a smart tactic I'm just saying that's
what they need to do to diversity I mean
maybe I think that you can probably
achieve diversity hires without going
for you could because the thing is if
you if you hire someone that said has
she her or he him pronouns right you're
you're probably going to get a person
that is just looking to go to work and
do their job and looking to just live
their life however they want if you hire
someone whose pronouns are Zer Zim
you're hiring someone that's going to
make your job a living hell they're
going to ruin your workplace they're
going to come in and they're going to
bring their ideal ideology along with
them and every business is going to be
like it is way easier to avoid people
that use Neo pronouns or they them
pronouns and just hire people that use
she and her and he and him you may end
up with trans people and that's fine
because they're just normal trans people
that are just looking to live their
lives not politically queer people that
are activists that are looking to ruin
your company that's a good point I think
in general that that's probably true
there probably I'm sure instances where
someone would have zizer and they're
totally cool but I think when you've got
to make huge decisions about thousands
of people you don't have time to go
person by person you've got to make you
know Split Second decisions and stuff
are people really putting their pronouns
like this is a normal thing because I'm
looking at templates right now and even
like the big websites aren't saying that
you should be putting your pronouns in
your this is probably not liar and
that's the reason it got such attention
because it's like yo I have one word of
business advice for people and this key
to know your audience so the only place
where pronouns in your resume might help
is I don't know Media Matters or the
ACLU or CNN but if you're applying
somewhere else then it probably wouldn't
be the best idea you always have to
tailor your resume a little bit to the
job you want so if it is a leftist
organization they probably would like
that they them or the pronouns in the
resume but otherwise probably your best
bet to not put it in here's here's the
issue it may be that very few people are
actually putting they them in their in
their resumes and the media looking for
some issue decides to write about this
Fringe group of people that aren't that
numerous here's an example this is great
Christopher rufo tweeted it's a sign of
immense progress that in a search for
racism Publications like the New York
Times have to invent increasingly Niche
and implausible incidents of supposed
bigotry such as woman with large
dreadlocks has trouble finding
equestrian helmet the New York Times
what an article says black equestrians
want to be safe but they can't find
helmets for Black Riders with natural
hair finding a helmet that fits can be
virtually impossible some are trying to
raise awareness for the problem but
manufacturers say it's not a simple fix
I love this because he was like quote
I'm having trouble finding a horse
riding helmet it's racism bro it's like
a white dude with dreadlocks too
so that like this is kind of the point
the media is like we found a person who
has chosen to have long hair and not a
helmet won't fit racism
that's the thing like CNBC writing about
non-binary people is just trying to
create some kind of Injustice narrative
to get clicks I get disability you know
build me a ramp so that I can get into
the front of the building I get that but
when it comes to like Dre my head
doesn't fit in your helmet you don't
force someone to build you a helmet
that's totalitarianism you build your
own Helmet or yeah you start a company
and hire people to help you make you go
to a helmet maker and be like I would
like a helmet that can fit my dreads and
they're going to be like bro your hair's
too big the helmet's got to be snug and
protect your brain
oh you show up at a place you say look
the helmet doesn't fit it's racism now I
get to be in charge that's literally
what they're doing it's a good idea
that's exactly what that's what that's
what critical theories are all stuff
races until you control it James Lindsay
right there new study that like 93 of
kids in this in America can now
demonstrate or understand at least one
tenet of critical race Theory like if
you thought about critical race Theory
five years ago thinking that it would
have a 93 success rate that's unreal I
question that that number though where
did you get is that like a poll or
something yeah it was like a thousand
people pulled yeah it's difficult to pin
down a tenant of critical race Theory
because it becomes this kind of
amorphous idea but I I understand more
but it's hard to learn talking about
school kids right these are kids that
are still in like uh K-12 yeah so I mean
the fact that these kids can identify
one of the Core Concepts of whatever
they'll call it social emotional
learning critical race Theory you know
their problematic tenants to be teaching
kids they know that it's critical race
Theory no no of course it doesn't matter
what it's called the because when you
start when you start when you start
labeling it the first thing that happens
is that is people that are pro whatever
it is they start telling you no we don't
they don't teach that they start lying
they'll change the definitions yes
they'll just lie to you so they're being
indoctrinated yeah yeah they're totally
being inducted 100 indoctrination it is
a cult basically yeah like communism is
a cult the whole the whole kitten
caboodle well like here's here's an
example actually because I just tweeted
something out I uh I saw a tweet from
the krakensteins for those aren't
familiar they're like prominent liberals
and Brian said dear Republicans if you
think drag queens reading books about
love and inclusion to your kids is bad
you might want to check out some of the
verses from the Bible that your local
priest is reading to them so I responded
with okay now try a non-theist adult sex
performers should not be around kids and
he said 100 I'm not aware of any sexual
performances that book readings are you
and uh there actually are they're just
first and foremost drag is an adult sex
performance yes and they're lying to you
they are lying to you and I'll say it
again they are lying to you when you had
these child drag queens ripping their
clothes off on stage for adult gay men
handing the money they said it's just a
costume change it's just a cast and I'm
like right when the go-go dancer in
states that have banned full nude
stripping are dancing on the pole and
then rip off their top and they're
wearing a bra it's just a costume change
no it's a sexualized adult performance
it's meant to titillate so when you when
you when you put a go-go dancer or a
stripper in a book club we would call
that an adult sex performer reading two
children
and they should they we shouldn't we
shouldn't do that and everybody replying
to that that's saying it's not
sexualized you're all lying garbage
people well they're just the worst evil
pieces of garbage there is why is it
always that it's we know it's sexualized
when it's straight but we don't know
it's sexualized or it becomes mumbled
like LGBT it's it doesn't make any sense
why is it all of a sudden not sexualized
because we're pushing a specific
ideological agenda because all
Communists lies I think a lot of it is
Blair white tweeted taking kids to a
drag show to teach them to respect gay
people is the equivalent of taking them
to a strip club to respect women yeah
isn't Blair white being an influencer
it's not as bad obviously as drag
queen's Story Hour but aren't you
normalizing the idea of trans people
almost as much if you have a transition
Blair white Blair white has every right
to be on the internet
and she doesn't but she realizes the
idea oh well some people would say
normalizing the eye the idea of being a
successful transgender person and being
conformed in that new identity is wrong
to teach children that because it could
lead them to think that no we don't
think that meant to happen but that's a
totally different circumstance Blair
white being on the internet talking
about
you know being Blair white being an
influencer having ideas is not the same
as showing up in a g string to a
children's reading hour or whatever or
to a bar telling the kids it's not going
to lick itself and then spreading your
legs and thrusting your hips in front of
someone's face Blair's very reasonable
she'll tell you like I'm a man and I'm a
trans woman and she can be both at the
same time in fact you have to be you
never stop being a man when you
transition to trans woman you never stop
it's you can be both at the same time
that's very important I guess the idea
becomes do you think she helps normalize
the idea the trend people can transition
successfully I actually just did an
interview with a mom who was she's in a
lifelong Democrat like blue dog Democrat
still lives in California and her
daughter underwent a phase when she
thought she was transgender grew up like
typical young girl like had like eight
dresses around her always wearing
dresses very cute very friendly
um and then went on to identify as a man
for about a year and a half and that was
a concern that that Mom raised um so I
don't think it's what specifically that
she said I you know I think my daughter
watched a lot of Blair white and that
this is what she she called us now do I
think that I'm not opining I'm just
saying that was a con that was a valid
concern of a mother who you know whose
daughter underwent all of this there is
an argument if if there is an argument
to be made surrounding this particular
issue about Blair white or trans people
that's an issue for parents to deal with
agree that's something for parents to
deal with with their children and
parents to act like children to raise
their children Blair white has every
right to get on it on YouTube and make
videos if she wants absolutely and to
even even discuss it in a way as if it's
somehow you know the onus is on Blair to
not do that is in my opinion absolutely
outside of of the bounds of and now
reasonable conversation thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time